by the power of castle hate skull i am
hella mark harley and you are watching
yet again one more week is it tuesday is
it wednesday is it thursday who knows
when this podcast is even coming out
anymore but i can guarantee you at some
point it's going to return to its normal
tuesday schedule all right i am in a
good mood i'm really excited right now i
have a few things to start off with
before we get into some even cooler
stuff so we're gonna start off with the
mildly cool stuff and then get to the
really cool stuff now
casey and i were just having a
conversation earlier
i put on my instagram that i'm the
buffest person on instagram and in case
you didn't know i'm gonna reveal it here
okay this has been a joke the entire
time there was no vote i decided was
something funny to put on my instagram
gasp casey revealed to me i know right
but people will actually come at me like
you that you like that's evidence of my
narcissism it's like oh you think you're
the buff i'm like oh
bless your heart um goofing buddy yes
just goofing around you know flew right
over your head when you can't detect
sarcasm
that is that obvious it's like ooh you
are either like really dumb or really
angry um casey however i learned he goes
he made a joke about being
cutest in his high school
i'm sure i prompted him with something
he's not just going around bragging
about being voted the cutest but i go oh
that's
you actually did and he's like yeah put
it you know cute cutest in my high
school that's democracy right this isn't
even casey bragging it's just going i'm
sorry there was a vote and people
thought i was the cutest person in this
high school one put to a popular vote
yeah your boy's the cutest yeah it's
just like dude let's keep it simple yeah
like not who has the best knows or the
best uh it's just like yeah because it
might have been a best eyes too right
yeah it's like best it's like yeah
but when we put them all together we got
the triple crown right who's got the
the biggest summation of all the parts
and that's a you boy so
that was a lead into a conversation
where i go i like because i i call casey
the internet's most handsome podcast
producer turns out i'm not the only
person who thinks that right he's been
kind of he it was it was uh it was
written that he would be the internet's
most handsome podcast producer even back
in high school people saw that he was
destined for greatness
mainly based on his looks right
the segment is making me blush mark
okay we'll move on then but i just
thought that was funny because also high
school superlative stuff it's like
you're the hottest
congrats but that's cool because maybe
maybe like you went on to do something
maybe other people that's like their
crowning glory in life you know they're
crowding achievement
okay so what's going on with me you know
we just i'm in a good mood actually
because i was just out of fight of the
kid where we watched the amber heard
trial
verdict live and i have to say
i love the truth one and you could take
a lot of angles on it like it's good for
male victims of abuse and i do think
that's true and i do think there's
going to be a change in the cultural
zeitgeist where
something that amber heard actually said
herself which was like go ahead go claim
that i johnny depp i'm a victim of
physical violence and domestic abuse
there are realities to this and of
course not every woman is lying but i
think it's very important
in the reason i was so fascinated with
this trial in part was because you got
to see the breakdown of what an actual
abusive dynamic looks like and part of
it is you go
did amber hurt ever look like she was
like being controlled or manipulated or
suppressed or that she was scared of
johnny depp because you really didn't
see that in any of the recordings and i
think that's this evidence of you know
short of video footage of people
hurting one another or physically
harming them you kind of you take this
holistic view and go
this is a situation in which it might
appear that somebody is
lying or completely making things up and
we'll get into the specifics of that and
a little bit i know we've touched about
touched on borderline personality and
various cluster b
types like sociopathy and narcissism and
borderline which have a lot of
overlapping traits and kind of
it's a category of people who are
capable of this type of deception
because of their lack of empathy and
because of their pathological
selfishness
they are that category of people that
would be willing to ruin somebody's life
for personal gain and
as somebody put
in a video the other day they don't
think about
i was watching this video and i'll try
to give her credit next time but it was
a woman who was talking about her
reaction to the
johnny depp amber heard trial as
somebody who faced narcissistic abuse in
the military or maybe sociopathic abuse
somebody who's in charge of her and of
course in positions of power
it's easy to
take advantage of that if you're one of
these power hungry types and
subjected this person to um just
terrible of you abuse over the course of
years at this like air force academy it
was a woman you know
harassing a woman and abusing her
psychologically
making false accusations against her and
she kind of goes through the whole thing
and just saw how like
she saw so much of her situation in the
johnny depp situation because
this person would make up just wild lies
like she like sat up like that like in a
you know confrontation or something she
was getting a false accusation and she
goes huh
and then the person goes did you see
that she just jumped across the table at
me like that type of thing where you go
like this person has no problems making
things up out of thin air
it's a dangerous personality type and
they're also going to manipulate
everyone around them you know to be
under their control to be afraid of
speaking out against them so it's not
just like you're combating a lie you're
combating a circle of people who have
been
primed to support this abuser and
you know it
it can be very difficult well they're
both crazy well okay one person is
telling the truth and and one isn't and
i think that's
it's very important that we saw that
blueprint and the truth one so that's
what i was really gonna say at first is
truth wins out it's not about like oh we
got one for the men which is true and i
think you know we should pay attention
more and you shouldn't be so quick to
dismiss a guy like john ended up saying
hey this is this is not true and it's
you know perhaps even the opposite um
i think we should all have more
education in general about this kind of
thing and what actual abusive dynamics
look like
i just wanted to tell you also i had a
10 minute deadlift workout
this morning i took 315 me and brendan
did it on the minute 10 sets 6 reps at 3
15 which is probably you know
less than half um no a little bit more
than half of my max if my max is like
550 you know let's say 60 or so of your
max
take that do six reps on them for 10
minutes let's say easy pretty much full
body workout in under 10 minutes if
you're pressed for time quote unquote
people always say that it's usually not
the case as far as carving out you know
10 to 15 minutes you all have that kind
of time
so
oh my god
casey we talked did we talk about this a
little bit this this
somebody sent me some information
this is a big
i'm so excited
so
you know i've been seeing a lot
on the subreddit recently that people
are making like fake
hella mark harley accounts and like
like
not even like to make fun of there was
like one that was like dr mark harley
and it's like you know his joke is to
write really like long wooden things
using
vocabulary words and make it but like
it's like you know i don't try to speak
in a confusing manner i may drop a
vocabulary word or two
into the situation if uh needed but he's
trying to satirize me from the
perspective of like
you know i'm using
uh pseudo-intellectual confusing
language which ah
you know you can tell me if that's true
or not am i speaking to you in
a vernacular that's designed to confuse
you
did the word vernacular confuse you
i had a conversation with a hater the
other day where the word antagonized
wasn't uh something that he was familiar
with so maybe if i'm dealing with a 19
year old idiot um
that would be confusing but
i don't know i don't i don't think of
myself as trying to insert language like
that what am i talking about here just
the fact that that was one fate where
it's obviously a joke but then a couple
popped up where it's like they'll spell
hella mark harley with like a capital i
so it looks like hell you know because i
own the domain hello mark harley on
reddit a couple put dashes in there
and like
made like put like a good picture of me
so they're like and then responding to
other people in realistic ways like
you know so that type of stuff it's like
oh you're you're going into a zone where
at least addressing it now it's like hey
you know let's put it out there you're
doing that and trying to make me look
bad but
it makes me feel less bad
for what i'm about to say and not that
i'm going to say now i'm going to allow
you guys to have this conversation with
me which is what are the ethics the
ethics of
uh exposing people who
harass other people online like let's
say you're somebody on reddit who's made
like 8 000 posts
all negative all all spending a lot of
time trashing certain individuals
on the internet
you know you might even be one of the
top posters
on a particular subreddit
and
devoted years of your life to harassing
somebody who i know who i think is a
good person
and uh that is also extended into
harassing me
by extension and also you know people
are trying to post my number on reddit
etc
good thing it's an old number but let's
say that's that's out in the
conversation right you're trying to do
this to me which i would consider a form
of doxing
that uh that phrase has been used
towards me many times for like putting
people's picture on ig but i don't think
that's the case so
if i'm just going like this is your
public profile here's a picture i'm
gonna put it on my story is that doxing
no however
some information was revealed to me
that it should it makes sense right when
somebody comes to you and they're like
hey
i put all this together and one of these
top people i downloaded all the
information from reddit and found out
who the top poster was and
cross-referenced it here and this has
nothing to do with brendan by the way
this has nothing to do with tiger belly
or anything it's just a random person
messaging me going hey this person seems
to have left some crucial identity
markers
in their reddit page that i went and
verified for myself and thought
that would be interesting
to tell you know the world about that
just to identify this person who spent
years harassing my friend
they also
have a story i think that
like i postulate here
like i hypothesize
many of these people
are unhappy or hurt or shame-filled
individuals
um
it's just a premise i can't verify that
for every single person who talks ill
with me on the internet but you you do
see some general patterns with little
clues that we can go okay that makes
sense right
this particular story
it makes a lot of sense i'll just leave
it at that if i were to tell the story
let's say
in next week's episode if you guys
comment below that you want to hear
about this
it it almost makes this person
as one of the top potential posters on a
subreddit it would sort of make them the
poster boy
or girl uh of the type of thing that
could happen to you
and would make you
turn into a
online hater right think about the
emotions that you would have to be
experiencing on a daily basis and how
you would view your life in order to
devote so many thousands of hours
over the course of several years to
putting other people down right
and
so i don't know i i still haven't
thought it all the way through because
this is this type of stuff is important
to me to think through the ethics of
because
i have an instinct one way and i have an
instinct the other way because i don't
actually want to cause harm
to anybody who does this stuff that's
disproportionate to what they've done or
even do it in the spirit of revenge
because really what i hope for everybody
who
you know takes it too far or just has a
fixation on
negativity or is spreading lies or has
pretended to be me or putting my phone
number up like
i don't even want to get back at you in
the same way i just want you to snap out
of it and i think that happens
something has to spur you and perhaps
exposing your real identity would
make you snap out of it and stop but
that's really the ultimate goal here for
me
yes i'm making myself look good but
it'll it is also genuinely true that i
don't want to
harm people i want y'all to stop because
it seems really
immature it seems really like
you're like a baby with a temper tantrum
and you haven't the self-awareness to
realize that this is something that
doesn't look good and is not a
productive use of your time and you're
wasting your entire life okay hey let's
take a break from talking about super
cool interesting stuff that my podcast
is filled with every week to talk about
something that i enjoy doing every time
before i film a podcast to make sure
it's the best podcast you've ever
listened to and that would be happy
hippo kratom you can go to
happyhippoherbles.com right now and use
code thick boy with three c's to get 20
off why do i like it because it's the
best ingredients the best quality the
best company and i urge you to try this
stuff out if you haven't done it before
use it responsibly let me know what you
think of it down in the comments and
also say what's up when you order
guys i know you're probably thinking wow
mark long sleeve button up and a cool
hat well guess what this shirt is from
oakenstoneclothing.com
my clothing sponsor for this podcast
and i love it i rocked this the other
day i posted it on my ig people were
loving it they're like oh my god can you
wear that again in your podcast i was
like yes i can
can i get 10 off i said actually it's
funny you'd ask that because yes you can
if you use code hella at
oaklandstoneclothing.com you can get 10
off you can be looking i like this you
can get some nice fitting short sleeve
stuff too whether that's button up
whether that's more athletic gear it's
made for the athletic guy in mind so if
you got muscles and you're tired of
shopping at ross and having everything
fit you like a garbage bag maybe go to
oakenstoneclothing.com and revamp your
entire life starting with your fashion
okay
moving on let's do a segment
called hella inspirational
have we done that before i don't even
know
but i just wanted to talk about george
for a second right
george harris if you don't know him he
is
uh he just got hired yesterday on his
birthday at thick boy um
he came here
to intern for 30 days
and
knowing behind the scenes what was going
on
it wasn't as if it was brendan's plan
the whole time to bring him on he was
sort of like i don't know you know
he he was involved in the question of
whether or not this is gonna work out
the back story of george coming here is
he was a fan of the fighter and the kid
and king of the sting and he submitted
when he was a 450 pound i believe he was
still in his teens but he was a a really
overweight guy and said
you know i've lost uh
200 pound and he might may have
submitted when he already had lost a
couple hundred pounds
but he submitted brendan was really
moved by the submission and said you
know if you lose this much more
i'll fly you out and you can wrestle
stevie weeby now stevie weeby whipped
his ass for sure but stevie wiebe is a
former elite high school wrestler
sure he wasn't marin county athletic
league champion of 2001 but
that's only one man and you're looking
at him but he's a really good wrestler
doesn't matter he flew out they put him
up in a cool hotel he had this amazing
experience
and he kept um
he kept in touch he kept loyal he kept
you know he would do things for us
sometimes it would be needed hey we need
somebody you know do this remotely can
you help out and he would
be there and offer his time and
you know it was very clear that he's a
loyal guy so he got flown out
he worked here for 30 days and
it's been really cool it's been really
cool to see him
at the office every day
to converse with him i know he gets here
early he leaves late he does whatever
he's i want to say this he's probably
the least entitled young person
perhaps i've ever met
but most certainly in l.a and that's
like you know
because people are like oh he's such a
good guy he is i love talking to him
he's really funny and he's very
insightful beyond his years and i just
genuinely enjoy talking to him every day
and i look i'd be nice to a younger
person at the office regardless you know
because i just i don't believe in the
hazing [ __ ] and you know being mean to
somebody for the for the sake of it for
making them feel bad and not want to be
there but
i would consider george an actual friend
and i think
we posted this video on the fire in the
kid yesterday and on brendan's page
where you know he announces on air that
he's getting the job and
it was a genuine moment and
i just wanted to kind of summarize that
and say
this is the result of hard work this is
the result of lack of entitlement this
is the result of somebody
being open being kind
being hard working
looking at things and going
i have a very difficult road ahead of me
you know whether that's losing several
hundred pounds whether that's leaving
your family
and coming to california
nothing has been easy for this guy he
also has been open with me about his
struggles with mental health and i think
that does give you insight into yourself
and the world um you know and and
if you go to therapy or whatever he just
i do think that that
helps you develop your maturity but i'm
just really proud of him and i just
don't want to say that like an arbitrary
we're like oh you got something cool you
got a job like he earned it and and his
position here
is
earned and fortified and if you're a
young person watching this i would just
recommend to you that you look at him
and go
what does that path look like what what
can i take away from this person because
i do think that word entitlement versus
not thinking anybody has oh you know
what's the opposite of entitlement not
believing that you're owed anything and
therefore
being willing to
work as if you're starting from zero or
below that you know when you look around
and go okay i was given these
disadvantages and i'm not going to sit
around and complain about it i'm going
to make up for those disadvantages in
other ways i think it's a great ro model
for
anyone to follow at any stage in life
okay
what are we 45 minutes in god damn
god
damn it
i just want to look at this um
overheard during the amber heard trial
here's a meme i overheard with my
eyeballs
it's captain jax but you always remember
this is the day you almost caught
captain jack sparrow
again i just think it's a fantastic
day for
the truth and i'm glad that other people
can recognize when a situate two people
because here's the the fallacy is always
well he's saying this and she's saying
that or tube doesn't have to be he she
could be in any situation could be
politics it could be whatever
the situation you know where people are
saying
this and then the opposite no it's up no
it's down
we have this notion
and it is a logical fallacy that that
the truth is somewhere in the middle
often it is not it can be binary it can
be either or
and you don't have to take the average
of the two claims and say well they're
both crazy or they both maybe visit
sometimes people just make things up
right and especially with accusations
and often with like political opinions
or you know
were you sort of debating something
theoretical one person can be totally
off but i love the fact that you can
look at this and you go we don't have to
compromise you can just say hey one
person
made this all up and that's is that
evident to everybody around her except
for the people that she's manipulated or
he has manipulated
and the answer today is yes and that
just restores my faith in humanity i was
not mentally prepared to accept i mean i
you know i would have been sad but like
i thought about what if they what if he
loses it's like man that would have been
a big moment for america where
i feel like we just kind of lose
some of us would lose faith in the
justice process and just the idea of
truth in and of itself that like you can
present something to somebody
so clearly with so many instances and
they're still like nah
yes this is a lot of serious stuff god
damn we'll come back to
okay how much can we play on youtube by
the way
like five minutes
at all if it's a jordan peterson video
it depends okay
i'll just i'll just summarize this
because there's a there's a
jordan peterson video on borderline
personality disorder guy asks him at a
lecture he's like hey man i you know i
saw that you
a couple times somebody asked you about
borderline personality and you sort of
demured
and said i don't have time to you know
like talk about it right now i don't
have the mental energy and it was
interesting because i'm like this is
such a smart guy whose expertise is in
psychology and even
then he was hesitant to speak about this
personality disorder and so i watch this
video when he finally gets into it
a few key takeaways were it's often
referred to as the
female
manifestation of
sociopathy right so it's like
men are predominantly sociopaths women
like if you took all people who had been
diagnosed with bpd
mostly they would be women and mostly
you know all diagnosed sociopaths are
men so could it be the female
manifestation of that he also says we
don't totally understand why it is what
it is um
you know it it's hard to maybe get these
people to go into therapy a couple other
takeaways i'm just spitballing off top
of my head but he talked about how
a lot of this behavior like when they
get really angry can manifest as almost
like an infant throwing a tantrum and
you kind of go by the time you're four
years old most kids grow out of throwing
tantrums and when you see it as a baby
sure they're like eating the carpet and
kicking their legs and it's almost cute
you know it's like terrible to deal with
if you're the parent it's annoying you
can walk away from it if you're in a
store
um but
he goes imagine you're seeing that as an
as an adult
right
like an adult throwing an actual tantrum
then it becomes scary and i'm like [ __ ]
man that that clicks in with like some
of this behavior that we see
from crazy people um but specifically
with these recordings of amber heard
like you see her a lot
or hear about these instances where
she's essentially throwing an adult
tantrum and it's something that most
people grow out of by the age of four
but if you don't and you're mentally
stuck
in infancy
you're doing stuff like that and again
the paradox that he points out and
articulates really well is
they have an intense fear of abandonment
and that's correlated with an
idealization and devaluation cycle where
you'd hear johnny depp talk about
how
you know the first year or whatever
there's this honeymoon period where she
seemed like the perfect person
if
the other person in the relationship
starts to give any sort of small
indicator that they're going to leave or
that things aren't right the borderline
personality is hypersensitive to those
cues and begins
predicting and anticipating that they're
going to be abandoned
fear of abandonment one of the defining
qualities
of this disorder
and start behaving the bpd starts
behaving in a way that pushes that
person away oh irony right but we see
that because we see somebody who's so
scared of losing johnny depp and would
you know send him a thousand messages
after he'd leave or she was so scared of
him leaving the room or going somewhere
else during an argument manifestation if
you're abandonment but paradoxically is
behaving in this way that would drive
anybody up the freaking wall
so i urge you to check that out
um
i think it's really interesting if
you're into this stuff and also just
that
like
he also goes into a discussion which i
want to bring up more in the future
conscientiousness extrovert all these
different five big five personality
things
are all
aspects of you know this talk that he he
talks about how conscientiousness
and iq have no correlation right you can
be a very smart borderline personality
and have no conscientiousness which
means
your ability to plan and execute things
you can plan you can strategize but
actually following through on it because
you're pathologically impulsive you just
can't seem to do it and because you
can't take responsibility or blame for
anything as part of this disorder
you then externalize it enrage at other
people your shortcomings and inability
to do certain things can't be reflected
upon yourself
because you're so hypersensitive to
criticism that you know that would
trigger depression or feelings of
emptiness so it's all going out here
so when my
podcast sucks it's like casey you're the
worst freaking producer i've ever met in
my life still cute though yeah you like
we're not gonna deny your cute but just
as like the skill of producing a podcast
you're garbage at it
you're fired okay
can we start the fun stuff now yeah now
that we're three hours into this yeah
somebody brought up on t5k i'm gonna say
a guy named brian callan brought up
mahmoud sebi he didn't send by name but
i said oh you're talking about an
egyptian wrestler at the att
american top team gym
in boca raton florida or wherever i
actually don't know if it's boca raton
probably not um it's somewhere near
miami i wish i knew the city off top my
head coral gables i think um
brian told this story of how amazing
mahmoud sebby's body was and i had to
look it up
and maybe rub one out but you know it
doesn't matter what i'm saying like
that's a possibility does that make me
gay i don't think so sexuality is fluid
now
let's check out this
dime piece and i just wanted to break
this down because do i think he's on
steroids i don't know i don't think he
is but here's some things
that you look for in a guy where you go
there's an optical illusion here that
makes him look more enhanced or look
like he's on steroids or people going by
like oh that can't be natural but
there's these qualities that you see in
a lot of fitness influencers for example
that that will make it look like
somebody's sort of more of an action
figure what do we see i'm seeing really
broad shoulders right if you have a
really broad hip to waist ratio
naturally and you see like he just has
super prominent
shoulder structure you can see that
right i'm not i'm not making things up
here
super broad shoulder structure also
leads to having a larger chest because
if there's more space between your
shoulders guess what the middle of your
backs is going to be wider so this guy
looks like he has really broad shoulders
and that actually makes your pecs bigger
so as a man like every guy wants big
pecs when they start working out
it just gives you a sort of broader
palette a broader um canvas
with which to paint those pecs on your
body
with weight paints
then you also see as really small waist
as i mentioned before
he has deep ab insertions right cause
some people like you could be born with
garbage abs i'm not gonna say any names
the rock but if you
look at him
you go okay this guy's got a six-pack
but like the abs like are etched really
deep you know and some people like you
could just have a sheet of muscle with
no striations no nothing in it and that
tends to look
um
not so good okay i don't want to body
shame anyone like the rock let's just
say for example that i'm criticizing his
abdominal muscles but if i were to name
somebody off the top of my head who's a
celebrity who uh could do you know a
zillion crunches and wouldn't have the
abs that mahmoud sebi does i'm just
saying this guy's genetically gifted
maybe he does do sauce i don't know
we'll have to have him on the podcast
and ask him once and for all clear it up
there's a lot of chatter on the internet
and we want you to come on and confront
those accusations
moving right along
do i even know what i clicked okay bro
science academy
because i'm dropping knowledge on you
guys like i said before with my 10
minute workout
a lot of people go mark your arms are so
big they're popping out of that oak and
stone shirt you're right they are but
here's the thing
i don't work them out that much okay
when i hit arms i hit them really quick
i do super sets and here's what it looks
like right here's the format
i'll go
if i'm starting with biceps for example
here's like a this shouldn't take you
more than 15 minutes and you actually
will kill your arms with it
start with either
a barbell preacher curl or a standing
bar curl and you can almost do anything
for it like like you could do a seated
dumbbell curl you could do a standing
barbell curl you could do a a preacher
curl with a ball with an easy curl bar
those are just three of my favs off the
top of my head but anything that's going
to put your wrist in a supinated
position right to really stress the
biceps and not hit the brachialis go
from that and you can usually use the
same weight let's say you do a set of
10 to 15.
i want you to do three sets
of that but superset at each set with a
reverse curl whatever you're doing
whether it's a cable curl standing at
that stack whether it's a a preacher
curl and then you can do standing
reverse curls uh you could take a
a seated uh you know
one arm at a time bicep curl um see the
dumbbell curl or a leaning back against
a slight incline you take that and then
you pronate your wrists right so you're
doing either a hammer curl or reverse
curl superset those things the logic
being you can use the same weight
because you're going to be stronger in
this motion you can hammer curl a lot
more
then you can curl like this so it's a
it's a different movement with different
emphasis on your arm but it builds your
forearms and your brachialis which
pushes out your bicep and makes
everything look bigger do three sets of
that you're gonna be toast all right
back to back
give it a little bit of rest between the
you know the this to that
the supination to the pronation how do
you remember supinated versus pronated
soup you're like holding a cup of soup
then after that here's one
triple set that you can do
that will kill your triceps
take again one weight right for me that
might be around
100 pounds 100 pound easy curl like pre
you know pre-loaded bar
do standing behind the neck tricep
extensions so i'm using a bar doing this
right
roughly to failure let's say that's ten
then i'm gonna lay down immediately no
rest and go into skull crushers right
gives you a you're going from something
that emphasizes the stretch and this is
a harder movement to do for most people
than a laying skull crusher because your
tricep is put in a less stretched and
more mechanically advantageous position
so you go to that to failure
and then you go from the laying skull
crushers into
a close grip bench press really close
you know should be about here
narrower than your shoulders to really
emphasize the triceps and burn out with
those do that three times and tell me
you don't have the most gigantic tricep
pump you've ever had in your lifetime
and
possibly previous lifetimes as well
if you don't like it if you don't get a
pump come to me and i will venmo you two
dollars
within 48 hours of you dm'ing me okay
that's my promise to you
and i've never broken a venmo promise
is that so are you guys cool with that
now you're going to get big arms it
shouldn't take you more than 10 minutes
if it takes you 30 minutes
i'm gonna say send me a video of your
workout
air drop it to me in person
go back home i'll look at it and then
get back to you
and tell you how you're [ __ ] up
did you think i was gonna forget the
liver king name of the week i don't
think though
i don't think so daddy
some of these are just so random okay
yeah
this is this is liver king shooting on
his property i would assume shirtless of
course
[Laughter]
i just love stuff because he's like
small
what's the next uh we got another meme
down there this is like what
some of these are just absurd but i love
it
it's him his legs are photoshopped to be
gigantic his upper body uh his upper
body probably looks the same his head is
shrunk and his arms are made to look
skinny as he's reaching up like this and
the caption is just i've completely lost
it
course i love this meme format where
it's like the buff guy like whispering
to a girl at a party who's uh super
uninterested
he says my turn
are you on the liver and bone marrow
train yet
is it that funny no do i like the use of
this meme to make fun of the liver king
of course and then the final one i don't
know if i've used this one before but
it's worth repeating even if i have
so
it's his wife laying down with the liver
king he's got his eyes closed he's got a
barbarian helmet on him
and then the wife's little speech bubble
says rad he's asleep put the phone down
and get your brother it's time to make
her escape
why is that funny because he forces his
lifestyle on his entire family guys and
if that's you if you're in a situation
where you're on the receiving end of
liver based and raw organ meat based
abuse get out now there are resources
for you to help
okay you know what i'm thinking about
dude
how like people love hella chef harley's
and how it's just crazy it's like oh
like what do i have to even
like what's the research i have to do
it's just going what did i eat this week
and here's something that i actually ate
multiple times this week
that i was like i gotta pass this
forward because
it's healthier than i kind of thought
and i'm
taking a certain ingredient out that i
like might make it less healthy or more
you know
dense in calories in a way that wouldn't
be desirable to somebody on a diet
however
have you ever eaten lox on a bagel i
know i have it's one of my favorite
things to order at restaurants if i see
it on there and i'm in the mood for it i
will actually order a 15 lox on a bagel
with cream cheese and with capers and
with tomatoes now you can still eat all
those things but i've been experimenting
with it this week
just doing the locks on a bagel
there's not a huge variation in you know
the same size bagel doesn't matter if
it's like cinnamon raisin or everything
and you're probably thinking to yourself
what kind of psychopath would have locks
on a cinnamon raisin bagel this
psychopath okay
see it wasn't a funny like i'm accusing
everyone else to being a psychopath but
turns out
i'm eating locks on a cinnamon raisin
bagel proof indeed
it's 633 calories if you take away the
cream cheese now you can put whatever on
i'm just saying like i bought this 25
two pack of uh locks at costco that
gives you four six ounce servings of
locks if you take like half of what's in
um
one of the packages and split that in
half
boom boom on each side of the bagel so
you get six ounces of locks one bagel
nothing else
you're punished and you can't eat food
that tastes good 41 grams of protein 43
grams carbs 11 grams of fat and it's 633
calories and guess what it takes
exactly as long as toasting the bagel
and putting locks on top of it would
take
which again if you're taking more than
three minutes to prepare this meal i
want you to take a video of it come see
me in person air drop it to my phone go
back home and then we can have a face
time conversation in which i berate you
for having poor time management skills
casey's like call on the kettlebell
time management huh
we were supposed to shoot this at 10.
i'll have casey berate you about time
management
and say this is exactly how you're
acting like mark
um
all right we're gonna finish up with
some this is why we can't have nice gems
because these are in fact several
reasons why we can't have nice gyms so
this is a little video here when my
friend goes to the gym for the first
time this is a very funny jim skit this
guy's doing like some good physical
comedy on the elliptical thing where
he's just like goofing around and kind
of keeping his head and upper body
stable
what i realized is that actually
triggers me
like when i say i'm like oh like i hate
when people goof around at the gym and
like you know me casey like give me you
know
throw me in a funeral and i'm gonna be
like doing something inappropriate at
least be talking at an inappropriate
volume guaranteed goofy
like but my friends
i i have a reputation amongst my friends
is like doing something that they're
going to go like this at like oh please
don't mark please don't um you know
don't don't make this joke where like
the cashier isn't in on it but you're
trying to humiliate me by like saying
something you know like i like to create
awkward triangles or like i'm acting
like an idiot and like it embarrasses
the person i'm with
who like i'm kind of framing as like my
caretaker or something like that which
is trust me i know it's unfair to
everybody involved but like that's how i
get off and so i'm looking at this going
like i hate when people goof out of the
gym because
you know why because i i don't want to
spend more time in the gym that i have
to so when i look at that i go like oh i
hate when i'm like lifting with somebody
and i've broken off like friendships
before because like i want to live with
you and then i lift with them and i'm
like you're wasting my [ __ ] time
leave my life
protein powder
what he's saying is [ __ ] your protein
powder that it cuts
okay
then there's a giant dick hole in the
middle of protein he's all sweaty saying
what's the next step
great joke great joe great stitch great
tick-tock doing the damn thing what's
that third video saying to us i'll show
you probably something cool i bet yeah
we don't even know about i know okay
this is another thing that triggers me
the gym because i only see gay men and
women doing it for whatever reason maybe
they're trying to show off the goods to
potential mates no
this is a woman using the smith machine
as a leg press which you actually see
pretty commonly why does it trigger me
because it's a perfectly good smith
machine and there's like 18 different
leg press devices in the rest of the gym
for some reason you need to put your
coochie out in the air and i don't mean
to body shame anybody and he would be
like oh dress inappropriate for the gym
wear whatever you want put your coochie
anywhere seriously
but this is just not how you use the
machine and like why would you do that
you have to unhook it with your feet how
heavy can you possibly go
why would you want to get trapped under
that there's just so many better ways to
do it it's one of these things that i
have to go like what is the reason
you're doing this you want attention
on your genitals
here we got a video of a woman hanging
kettlebells
right
and then it says the baby
holding on to this rope in the womb
ish oh wait is she actually pregnant i
didn't realize it at first
because she's like thin and has a black
shirt on
it kind of does look like she's pregnant
right uh i wouldn't okay
that's also one of the rudest things you
can do is say yeah how's when's the baby
due and the woman goes i'm not pregnant
you're like i was kidding and then you
go kill yourself
don't do that guys it's just a joke like
you would feel so much embarrassment
over it
good one moving on
this is okay
this is a guy who i discovered recently
his name is cousin vlad he's
an australian guy and i just love the
way he told the story so we're gonna
we're gonna end on this
hey and they set me on this table with
my cousins that i haven't seen for years
my distant cousin goran the power leaf
gorilla he was sat right next to me
he saves me vlad how are you doing bro
long time they say you're looking
shredded are guys
180 kilos he goes 140 but thanks for
asking thanks for asking no worries bro
obviously you're still doing heavy
weights powerlifting he goes yeah bro
gotta keep doing that but he'll sat like
on the side the whole time all awkward i
thought something was wrong with his
back i go goron what's wrong with you
why are you sat off the side of the sea
like that he goes nothing bro i go what
is that he goes
bro it's all the years of powerlifting
the roads have caught up i go i told you
bro stop putting that [ __ ] in your body
who knows what is he going [ __ ] in my
body this is stuff coming out bro it's
hemorrhoids not steroids
yes that was a long setup for
a steroid hemorrhoid joke but i he
sucked me in so i give it up to you
cousin vlad
you nailed it i'm gonna be telling that
story ineffectively because i don't have
your accent but you know it's just a
classic mix-up casey what are we gonna
do all right now
that's gonna wrap up this episode calmly
peacefully remember i want you to
comment in the section below what would
you do if you were in my position
and you had access to some information
about people who i don't know maybe
harass your friends like 8 000 times in
the course of two years would you say
the real name would you not what would
you do
tell me if you were in my position in
the comments below
should i expose them like i'm
exposing my chest from this oak and
stone
clothing
actually ripped a button off [ __ ]
you